bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7 une culture et tout
le sommaire de ce mercredi 27 juin du
théâtre du one man de la musique de la
danse pour sa saison 2018 2019 le
théâtre espace coluche à un mot d'ordre
tous au théâtre
nous ferons le point sur la
programmation comme chaque année
l'orchestré symphonique alphonse daudet
est en concert un concert de musique
légère où vous pourrez notamment aux
tendres du classique comme de l'opéra tu
es à bougival la vis à vis à redon est
en péril à l'abandon la bâtisse est
pourtant un lieu de foisonnement
culturel
la cantatrice et son mari ait invité de
grands noms de leur époque la villa a
été choisi par stéphane bern pour
bénéficier du loto du patrimoine plus de
30 rendez vous pour tous les goûts au
théâtre espace coluche de plaisir on
vise une saison éclectique
nicolas kirillovitch et jules greenville
pour la technique
[Musique]
tout se paie après l'invitation est
lancée à plaisir la ville débute sa
saison le 22 septembre le directeur du
théâtre espace coluche nous attend pour
faire le poids
[Musique]
l'enfant desnos bonjour bonjour alors
2018-2019 rimera avec diversité
j'allais dire comme toujours puisque
c'est vraiment la mission qui m'a été
confiée par madame le maire d'avoir une
programmation éclectique et diverses
donc diversité toujours spectacle pareil
toujours on essaye de garder une
fréquence de spectacles parce que si on
enlève des spectacles parce que la vie
coûte de plus en plus cher mais on va
relever du public et un moment il y aura
plus personne donc c'est toujours
maintenir et un niveau de qualité
on essaye ça s'est un peu présentes
présomptueux mais tant pis mais qualité
et quantité chez vous la saison débute
avec de l'humour celui de karim duval
oui alors je lis moi je ne connaissais
pas je les ai découverts avignon vive le
festival d'avignon glof ça c'est
vraiment le spectacle de lancement de
saison
[Musique]
rien de scientifique mais bon
dans le temps on avait des créations et
là c'est plus difficile d'en avoir
maintenant donc moi j'essaie de de faire
découvrir mes coups de coeur j'allais
dire d'avignon sur un spectacle gratuit
de lancement de saison qui nous permet
aussi de relancer le public pour leur
dire ben voilà venez venez au théâtre il
ya plein de beaux spectacles sa
causticité
sans être méchant parce que l'humour
vache comme l'amour vache d'ailleurs
c'est pas bien qu'avec l' île et ça
pique un rapide quand il envoie des
vannes parfois mais c'est pas méchant
et donc c'est très drôle ce qui marque
aussi sur votre saison c'est la place à
la musique et de toutes les musiques
toutes les musiques
oui c'est bien que vous me lancer sur
toutes les musiques parce que ça va être
michel jonasz mais ça va être aussi
celle à qui revient sur scène
moi j'étais allé la voir au casino de
paris les banques quand même celle là
mais c'était génial parce qu'elle s'est
fait accompagné d'un groupe qui
s'appellera hashtag elle est devenue
très rock et ça passe très très bien
et puis on a aussi plaza francia
orchestra qui est je ne sais pas si vous
avez eu le temps de remarquer mais c'est
anciennement gotan project
donc c'est quand même très haut niveau
voilà et on a du flamenco on a de la
musique gitane respect du gospel pour
ouvrir la saison aussi voilà et pour
profiter de cette grande salle est cette
grande scène vous faites aussi de la
comédie musicale un grand écart aux
comédies musicales des vastes mois le
livre de la jungle
sawyer il ya la photo n'est pas pour
tous les goûts alors directement en plus
c'est intéressant c'est dans le cadre du
festival sur le handicap qui le festival
qui s'appelait anciennement orphée
qu'ils s'appellent imago maintenant des
vastes moi c'est avec emmanuel laborie
molière quand même mais pas n'importe
quelle comédienne et tom sawyer et ben
voilà on passe des vastes moi qui est
une création à tom sawyer qui est une
création aussi mais moins contemporaines
qui est gelée vu aussi à paris en fait
de façon les spectacles que je programme
je les vois parce que sinon c'est pas
intéressant et c'est vraiment très très
bien fait c'est très très bien fait donc
ça s'appelait vraiment à tous les
enfants sachant que le livre de la
jungle
ce n'est pas la partition de molly ce
n'est forcément ça a été réécrit et
c'est le spectacle qui refaire par la
ville aux enfants scolarisés à plaisir
il ya aussi une belle place pour le
théâtre toujours de grands noms de la
scène il faut lire dans les
distributions sont notamment il ya douze
hommes en colère c'est que son père
comme ça sans sourciller
quelles sont ses juges une avance comme
aujourd'hui c'est du temps perdu au
moins on est sûr que cette affaire avait
l'équivalent coupable lève la main
11 votes coupable vous le croyez nous
sommes je n'en fait rien on va vous
étiez au procès comme nous tous une
autre personne a poignardé son père avec
un couteau
et quand on suit on va la fin w un
certain bruno wolkowitch absolument
voilà et donc douze hommes en colère je
me souviens d'un ami qui m'a dit comment
tu programme douze hommes en colère avec
tout le monde connaît l'histoire mais
oui mais elle reste absolument
passionnante
depuis le film est là c'est vraiment
très très bien fait aussi on a douze
hommes en colère on a fausse note avec
tenez vous bien pas des moindres
christophe malavoy est à vendre
on a meilleur allié qui est une
compagnie sont des comédiens belges sur
le dernier entretien que les derniers
entretiens qu'ont eus de gaulle et
churchill d'avant la guerre
on a silence on tourne qu'es tu ne
comédie mais drolatique avec notamment
patrick haudecoeur voilà on a vraiment
plein de pièces de théâtre
à chaque fois on essaye c'est j'essaye
c'est ma dernière saison
c'est une petite surprise pour les
spectateurs et vous parlais tout à
l'heure des plus jeunes ce que
d'ailleurs spectacle offert aux plaisirs
roi vous les oubliez jamais c'est déjà
lui à tom sawyer notamment tom sawyer et
puis c'est moi c'est pareil ça fait
partie de mes missions mais ça fait ou
pas aussi partie des choses auxquelles
je crois profondément que les enfants
s'ils viennent au spectacle jeunes alors
on va les perdre à un moment parce qu'il
va y avoir le judo le foot la musique
etc
donc on va les perdre à l'adolescence
mais hier à cette petite graine qui aura
été plantés pour que j'espère qu'il
revienne au spectacle un jour
donc on a toujours un spectacle par mois
le mercredi
ici pour les enfants en familiale on a
des spectacles pour les scolaires et
puis ces grandes comédies musicales
spectacles familiaux le dimanche en
matinée ou le samedi en matinée c'est un
samedi mais en général c'est la question
piège mais ce qu'il ya un coup de coeur
un spectacle à ne pas rater ces essais
c'est la question piège à laquelle je
répondrai pas je ne peux pas avoir un
coup de coeur parmi tout ce que j'ai
programmé puisque tous ces spectacles
que j'ai programmé ce sont les
spectacles pour lesquels j'ai eu un coup
de coeur en les voyant à paris ou
l'union et qu'il fallait seulement vous
fassiez de niro tech qui me paraissaient
dégâts hélas certains sont des évidences
je ne peux pas ne pas le programmer et
en fait tout ce sont les spectacles que
j'aime que j'ai vu avignon ben là je
vais avignon cet été jean voir une
quarantaine silence ordis ce sont
forcément des spectacles que j'ai aimé
que j'ai envie de proposer au public et
je dois dire pour ça que j'ai toujours
cette chance mais depuis 10 ans
maintenant extraordinaire d'avoir une
une carte blanche une malibu une
confiance totale de de madame le maire
et ça c'est travailler dans des
conditions comme ça c'est exceptionnel
alors on vous connaît comme directeur du
théâtre espace coluche a blessé les 25
et 26 mai une particularité dans la
programmation c'est une autre facette de
vincent desmons sur scène tout à fait
j'ai repris il ya un an à la demande
d'un metteur en scène qui s'appelle
vincent rouvet j'ai repris mon métier de
comédien en pensant un petit peu qu'à un
moment j'allais arrêter de travailler
ici puisqu'il y a un moment faut laisser
la place aux aux plus jeunes donc a
priori si tout se passe bien je partirai
fin juin 2019 et madame le maire et
l'adjoint à la culture ont vu ce
spectacle ils l'ont aimé c'est double
jeu de robert thomas ils l'ont eue mais
et en cadeau de départ voilà ils m'ont
proposé de jouer ici pour la dernière
représentation de la dernière saison des
dérivés ça veut dire des horreurs des
tirs ni trop pourquoi le besoin de ce
fruit
cette hypothèse en séries alors c'est
pas de faire ce chaque mois je tire une
balle dans la tête voilà les insultes
puis sens plus à l'aise que dans le mélo
je ne dérange pas à mon cher mais n'a
pas du tout pas du tout je vous présente
ma femme françoise ce certaine et ami de
longue date
on pourrait même dire de longue date
j'ai beaucoup entendu parler de vous
mais jusqu'ici je n'avais que le plaisir
de voir mes chèques mais vous connaissez
donc s'il ya plus intéressant moi car
j'imagine que vous avez fait faire une
enquête
non inutile et charles hamelin la rumeur
publique le temps tam du monde du
business c'est un très très beau cadeau
un très bel hommage
oui oui oui puis je puis je vois bien
que le public et est intrigué de me voir
dont il dirige à voir du monde
c'est la photo merci vincent
alors pour ne rien rater de la saison
plaisir one direction le site internet
du théâtre espace coluche c'est la
maison symbole d'une histoire d'amour
poétique celle qui lie et l'écrivain
ivan tourguéniev et la cantatrice
pauline viardot un patrimoine
aujourd'hui en péril qui sera restaurée
grâce au loto du patrimoine la maison
fait partie des 18 monument sélectionnés
par stéphane bern regarder de la chambre
de pauline viardot il ne reste plus rien
des salons où était donné concert et bal
il ne reste que quelques peintures la
ville 1 est aujourd'hui en péril laissé
à l'abandon
en 2000 je lui retrouvé pour la première
fois donc cette maison qui qui
représente tellement pour un musicien et
donc je suis rentré dans ses salons et
j'ai eu mal au coeur je les ai pleuré
pour tout vous dire comment était ce
possible d'abandonner un haut lieu de la
musique
le domaine est acheté en 1874 par la
cantatrice son mari et le romancier ivan
tourguéniev un lieu de foisonnement
intellectuel dont ces salons et c'est ça
qui est absolument magnifique
nous avons lu tous les grands esprits du
19e siècle
de l'oural à l'atlantique il y avait des
russes s'il y avait des néerlandais il y
avait des belges il avait des italiens
des anglais a probablement écrit
certains passages du david copperfield
ici qui ont fait de cette maison un haut
lieu de dialogue un haut lieu d'une
conscience européenne qui se dessinait
de juin à cette époque là des travaux
dont le montant s'élève à près de 3
millions d'euros le site a été retenu
par le loto du patrimoine dont le
premier tirage se fera le 14 septembre
prochain
non seulement c'est la reconnaissance de
ce que cette villa représente 3 millions
d'euros c'est une énorme somme notamment
pour une ville comme bougival qui est
une petite ville de 8000 900 habitants
et donc il est absolument essentiel que
l'état que les institutionnels
s'emparent de ce sujet et permettre la
rénovation de la villa une fois rénové
la villa intégrera un projet touristique
et artistique un grand centre de musique
et que la maison bizet composa son opéra
le plus célèbre carmen le château de
versailles a fêté l'été en costume
depuis 2011 le grand bal masqué
célèbrent les fêtes royales de la cour
une soirée de balade à travers les
jardins pour profiter des grandes eaux
musicales conclu par un feu d'artifice
d'une quinzaine de minutes
plus de 2000 personnes ont le temps
d'une soirée vécue le faste de louis xiv
les instants ont été capturés par
michael ni d'euros et pour prolonger le
rendez-vous les jardins de l'orangerie
vont se parer de feu à partir du 29 juin
le collectif pyrotechnique groupe f
célèbre la figure historique de
marie-antoinette l ai raconté stéphane
bern un extrait de la bande annonce
chers amis bonjour c'est stéphane bien
cet ep le château de versailles
célèbre l'exceptionnel destin de la
dernière reine de france marie
antoinette dans un spectacle
pyrotechnique du groupe f
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
on revient au présent ou presque notre
invité front sauvette et le responsable
de l'orchestré du théâtre
alphonse daudet de coignières et le
vendredi 29 juin c'est votre dernier
concert pour la saison 2017-2018
bonjour tout haché alors je ne suis pas
le directeur du théâtre faisait je suis
directeur
alors ce concert du 29 juin c'est un
concert de musique légère qu'est ce que
la musique légère musique légère pour ce
concert-là ça veut dire musique facile à
entendre facile à comprendre
ça va de un peu de musique de film
un compositeur américain qui s'appelle
le vrac anderson musique très sympa très
très joli très poétique légère dans le
sens et des oeuvres courtes et puis
c'est la musique que dit on un peu un
peu facile pour tout public que les gens
puissent trouver leur compte
sur une musique un peu plus profonde et
puis passer comme ça tranquillement sur
une musique facile alors en programmes
différents styles vous en avez nommé
améliora du classique de l'opérette et
de la musique de tout à fait dans le
classique on va aller voir du côté de
edward grieg puisqu'on joue un extrait
de période
d'autres classiques on va jouer aussi
une pièce qui s'appelle la danse des
sabots en bois
alors ça c'est drôle puisque en fait
c'est un ballet on imagine par
l'orchestration que les sabots se met à
danser tout seul c'est pour ça que c'est
aussi un peu léger puisque c'est plutôt
humoristique ce sont des pièces que vous
redécouvrez ans que vous dans votre
carrière vous avez déjà joué que vous
rêviez de remettre avec notre âme en 20
ans avec votre attitude peu des deux il
ya des oeuvres qu'on n'avait jamais joué
puis il est jeune qu'on avait déjà joué
et qu'on reprend pour le contexte pour
le pour la fête du côté de la musique de
film j'ai cru comprendre que russell
lawrence d'arabie
c'est très marqué un grand coup
maurice jarre tout à fait nous est fait
avec les magnifiques yeux de peter
o'toole
voilà donc on vous sait plus si klaus
hrc des pièces qui sont dures à à
travailler vous réguliers depuis
longtemps on répète depuis notre dernier
concert avril laurence d'un avis c'est
pas facile ouais c'est il ya des
passages très techniques
et puis les passages très chanter fin le
thème que souvent on connaît il faut pas
sous paie quoi alors sur scène vous êtes
50 vous dirigez 50 musiciens il ya une
particularité ce sont des amateurs chez
vous tout à fait tous les musiciens ont
donc un parcours musical eux avancent et
effectivement ils sont alors nous ont
dit non professionnels c'est pour pour
faire la différence parce que parfois le
mot amateur une connotation un peu
bizarre chez les chez les gens donc
voilà non professionnels c'est des
musiciens du très très bon niveau il ya
certains qui sont passés par le
conservatoire d'autres qui étaient
professionnels et puis ont arrêté leur
métier voilà donc qui font partie leur
castres a formaté de leur caisse et vous
répéter chaque semaine ce sont des
répétitions intenses j'imagine avaient
tous les jeudis de 20 heures 2 heures au
théâtre à son hôtel alors de temps en
temps j'imagine que quelqu'un
professionnels se glisse parmi vous pour
pour aider ensuite fait peut-être un
souffle
c'est ça quand on a des concerts dans le
cas de la saison ou au théâtre
effectivement
on demande à des musiciens
professionnels de venir ça c'est donner
un coup de main c'est donner de
l'énergie rassurer au dernier moment les
musiciens etc
ça marche bien et ce sera le cas le 29
juin ou alors là c'est ce passionné qui
se rendent cette journée tout seul on
est tout seul sur scène on aura notre
ami jacques tizié professionnel qui
vient et qui vient jouer avec nous une
pièce justement de l'oreille henderson
qui s'appelle forgotten dreams
magnifiques pages de piano et puis il
avait envie de deux pianistes dans l'
orchestre
voilà c'est il a découvert ça l'an
dernier il ya truc c'est un formidable
quoi d'être un des musées dans est ce
qu'on peut remarquer aussi dans notre
orchestre de tous les âges vous visez
très très large pour montrer que la
musique est accessible à tous et
peut-être aussi l'idée de faire
découvrir au public à moi je pourrais
jouer aussi avec dans quel sens phonique
de daudet non il est un peu cette idée
mais c'est surtout parce que il faut
qu'un orchestre de musiciens non
conventionnelles une moyenne d'âge qui
n'avance pas trop dans le temps parce
qu'après c'est plus compliqué si si
enfin j'essaye tomber les musiciens dans
des programmes divers et variés et si la
moyenne d'âge est un petit peu avancé
c'est plus compliqué donc il faut avoir
des jeunes des moins jeunes et autres
anticorps laisser défaire le mélange
il faut que les jeunes tirent un peu les
moins jeunes et les moins jeunes et
donnent leurs leur métier leurs
expériences et en fait si ce n'est une
certaine savoir vous ouvrez la fête de
la colère souffle week-end de juin voilà
quand en plus le temps est de la partie
donc ça veut dire que le samedi il y
aura plein de monde est plein jet un
magnifique feu d'artifice donc il faut
que le vendredi on démarre par feu
d'artifice musical
super merci françois feuillet d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors je le
rappelle votre orchestre se produit ce
vendredi c'est à dire le 29 juin au
théâtre alphonse daudet de coignières et
les premiers mouvements de baguette du
chef dans casquette avec moi c'est à
20h30
on parle encore un tout petit peu
musique cette fois que la fête de la
musique c'était jeudi dernier le 21 juin
bien sûr mais certains mélomanes ont
joué
les prolongations à guyancourt la fête
c'était le 23 juin le samedi à la
batterie élèves de l'école de musique
groupe en devenir ou confirmés
nicolas landry pour les images
[Musique]
oui
un début tout en douceur avec l'école de
musique à guyancourt la fête de la
musique a mis en avant les talents
locaux comme ses élèves clarinettistes
il ya toutes les formations je croque
quasiment tout ce produit c'est vraiment
le peut-être le moment phare de l'année
passée un choix en même temps on a le
droit de faire que du classique le jazz
mais ouais on aime bien toucher un petit
peu
à tous les sites à tous les styles
répartis au monde c'est de la bonne
musique à la batterie on a vu les choses
en grand
cinq scènes et 40 groupes et artistes
tous les styles tous les âges et même
des renaissance
les rockeurs de sans limites se sont
reformés pour l'occasion c'est pour
permettre sans limite d'âge
aa je vais te dire un peu de moi j'ai 66
bas on a tous 60 ans qua non pour lui
qu'on est potes depuis que les connais
tu lis ces gaz y en a pas moins que
simon ou plus que des groupes qui se
dessine à à la professionnalisation
comme les jam walker qui ont gagné le
tremplin de la batterie l'année dernière
et puis d'autres effectivement qu'ils
sont là
juste pour le plaisir qui répète une
fois par semaine comme d'autres vont à
la piscine au fond du macramé
du tricot chaque année ce rendez-vous
attire près de 4000 oman toujours à
guyancourt puisque là ce sont les arts
plastiques qui sont à l'honneur jusqu'au
3 juillet sortie d'atelier rassemble les
créations des artistes locaux et
amateurs tissage de papier carnet de
voyage oeuvre collective toutes les
techniques travaillées au cours de
l'année sont représentés avons avec la
maire de la commune elle était au micro
de camille lambert à guyancourt on a une
vraie richesse avec tous nos habitants
et on a des artistes n'est donc c'est
bien effectivement tous ceux qui ont
envie de re d'exposer et bien on leur
donne cette possibilité et on voit des
choses extraordinaires
[Musique]
le rendez vous cinéma de la semaine
celui de marilyn poupart tout de suite à
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois le coup de coeur de
l'espace philippe noiret cette semaine
c'est les images vagabond donc un
festival organisé par l'association
contrechamp donc c'est la septième
édition
alors on a plusieurs événements
commencent jeudi avec une soirée autour
d'un documentaire peu des fusées écoles
en vie sur trois enseignants de l'école
publique qui ont choisi une pédagogie
active et surtout s'interroge sur le
rôle d'enseignant et ensuite samedi
après midi on a une après-midi
d'événements avec trois films pour trois
publics différents
donc ça commence à 14h avec avril et ne
montre ou qu'est un très beau film rétro
futuriste injustement boudé lors de sa
sortie en salle pour lequel on propose
un atelier imagine-t-on mon truc et
ensuite à 16h30 le professeur balthazar
là c'est vraiment pour le plus jeune
public donc à partir de 3 ans et puis on
finit avec un jour ça ira à 18 heures
c'est un documentaire qui s'attache donc
à suivre deux adolescents dans un centre
d'hébergement d'urgence
l'archipel au coeur de paris et ces
adolescents vont être accompagnés dans
des ateliers d'écriture et deux champs
et tenter de dépasser leur situation
tout cet après midi donc du samedi sera
accompagné de goûter venez nombreux
[Musique]
encore quelques rendez vous à noter dans
vos agendas à la merise vous partez pour
les états unis et ses bars clandestins
les speakeasy la compagnie rade pack
vous fait découvrir un nombre de
gangsters de cinéma mais aussi de cirque
au programme machinois danse et
acrobatie déclic fait la fin de l'année
avec son traditionnel tournoi inter
générationnelle sur la scène de l'école
de musique de danse et de trappes vont
s'affronter toute la famille de déclic
des plus jeunes aux comédiens
professionnels
la réservation est par contre
indispensable sur le site de la
compagnie et avant de se quitter une
information sur deux collectes d'objets
notamment ses les villes de magny les
hameaux et celle de maurepas qui sont à
la recherche de photos de documents ou
d'objets de poilus de la grande guerre
pour cette année 2010 8 cette année
centenaire alors pour elle pour magny
les hameaux
vous pouvez vous rapprocher du service
de la vie associative à nos repas
dirigez-vous vers le club de généalogie
racines de maurepas elancourt c'est la
fin de ce site une culture merci de nous
avoir suivis vous pouvez nous retrouver
en replay sur notre site internet tv 78
points comme merci à mercredi prochain
[Musique]